SPEAKER: The American embassy
was like the symbol
of American imperialism
right in the center of Tehran.
(CROWD YELLS)
(SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE)
(CROWD CHANTS)
SPEAKER 2: I go to the window,
and I look out.
I see a vast crowd of people.
The embassy alarm system
goes off, people are yelling.
Finally, we just surrendered.
(CROWD YELLING)
SPEAKER 3: I gave up my weapon.
They blindfold me.
I thought that was it for me.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
REPORTER: The American embassy
in Tehran is in the hands
of Muslim students tonight.
REPORTER 2: They're holding
the Americans hostage.
It's an extraordinary act
and an audacious act
to humiliate the United States.
SPEAKER 4:
And it was having a big impact
on the American public.
SPEAKER 5: We were helping
the American people
to understand
the consequences of the actions
of their government in Iran.
SPEAKER 6:
There was an unholy pact between
the United States and Iran.
In one word,
the special relationship...
SPEAKER 7: It seemed to me
that the oil wealth
wasn't trickling down
to the people.
And that made me very angry.
SPEAKER 2:
The social fragmentation,
the corruption.
That was the fuel.
Khomeini was the match.
(CROWD CHANTS)
The revolution became a monster.
I thought we were gonna
have freedom.
They were just absolutely
convinced that we were spies.
SPEAKER 2:
My interrogation was unpleasant.
Let's put it that way.
The hostages have been there
for almost a year now.
This is gonna be the basis
of this election.
SPEAKER 8:
This was totally televised.
And it was very
television friendly.
Carter was convinced
that he could solve this.
He never dreamed
it would go on 444 days.
SPEAKER 9: How do you think
this will all turn out?
SPEAKER 10:
Why did this go on for so long?
I never thought of myself
as a hero.
I wanted to make it home.